hello and welcome to the 25th PHP
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be talking about time and various ways
to display time formats and here I've
just commented real quick a bunch of
stuff about time and then also this link
to time I mean there's just like there's
a million different letters and stuff
that we can use to denote all kinds of
different stuff when you're making a
date stamp and so you can find it all
here is php.net is actually really good
for just about every documentation type
and with PHP em it's incredible so
anyway there's that and expect you to
understand what this means just yet but
I'm going to show you so going right off
long we've got the most basic way really
to display time is just what's called a
unix timestamp that's number of seconds
after january first nineteen seventy so
the way this is displayed let's just
echo out a unix time and then we'll make
a break here and then we want to echo
out time and then note nothing in the
brackets period actually let's just
check out time so we'll just do that
first and save it pop over here refresh
unix time and then that's that's a unix
timestamp just a large digit or integer
and so that's not I mean that's nice
it's good the point of unix times it's
like you know the same for everybody and
it's convertible it's very universal
it's a good word for it but it doesn't
look very pretty and if you're you know
let's say you have a news site you want
to print out the time that something was
posted or a forum or something like that
if you print this out like doesn't
really help anybody so instead what you
can do is start to convert so how do you
convert unix time well i'm so glad you
asked so what we can do now is let's
ahead and appends and breaks to this so
we'll just append to break so we've got
ass line of space and what we'll do is
we'll call our variable date we'll call
it date stamp and that's going to equal
day and within date you have two
parameters the first parameter is how
you want that date to show up so for now
we'll just leave it right the next
parameter is what you want to apply that
to so say you had a variable that equal
time you can put that variable in there
like if you said like if you said unix
I'm sorry unix time oh my goodness unix
time equals up time right if you said
that then you would you would throw unix
time in here ok but really work for this
we're just going to throw in time here
so so now we can specify how we want
this time to be displayed if you type in
if you want to type in a word like today
is whatever you have to escape the
characters there might be a better way
to do this if you know the better way to
do this go ahead let me know might be
using maybe double quotes so now I don't
know but if you want to like say you
wanted to just say the you would have to
do th e like that and that will escape
every single character because as we can
see up here letters mean all kinds of
different things so you don't want it to
be confused so with that let's just do
an easy one let's say we want to do this
is the number of the month two digits
and this is without any leading zeros
let's do so let's keep this fairly basic
let's just do the month the day in the
year so there's not too confusing let's
just do a numerical month with the
leading zero you can also get the
numerical month without a leading 0 so
like if it's a
februari this will be 0 2 and then this
would just be up to and so let's do a
month day year and let's just keep
everything nice two-digit format so
we'll do em and then you can specify all
kinds of different stuff like we could
do em day year like that but most people
are going to want to have like it /
probably so M day why okay so let's save
that and let's put that and see what we
get oh we need to echo it out so first
let's echo this out um echo and thus a
date stamp colon and like a couple
breaks and then will echo date stayin
put that up and we refresh and we get
627 13 which is indeed the correct date
for me so now what can we what else can
we do with this obviously you can put
like this you know we just got the month
day and year but then you can start
doing time formats and all kinds of fun
stuff so let's go ahead and throw some
more stuff in here like if you want to
do the month the day of the year let's
do a space and actually that's change
this up let's make it pretty crazy so
let's say we want to do so let's say we
want to say like today is let's say we
want to do the day of the week full day
of the week then the number of the month
period and then a timestamp and then we
even want to add in the time zone of
that time stamp oh man it's going to get
crazy in here so to do that let's start
over we'll just make this empty so first
we want the day of the month or I'm
sorry the day of the week
so that is going to be and l a lowercase
l then we want to say so let's say we
want it so it's going to say thursday
the blank of for today let's say are
actually yeah so let's say we want to
say yet today will be thursday the 27th
of jun 2013 so this stuff gets kind of
confusing after a while but i just want
to show you how you can make a pretty
complicated one so let's do a so we want
to say thursday so that's done space and
then escape the t escape the h escape
the ee so to say the and then we want it
to say the day of the month or the
numerical day and let's do the one
without leading zeroes right so number
of the month so let's do j right so you
don't want to say oh six of the month
now you say the six or whatever in our
case it's the 27 so it won't matter
either way but it was a lowercase J so
we'll do j and then to get that like
sucks to get that suffix so to speak i
don't have it in my list but it's
natural it's an uppercase s so this will
be like six the second and so on so and
then we want it to say of so again we
need to escape the Oweis cape the f then
we want the month and we want the full
month let's see if we guess so we've got
that with the upper case F so the full
month f then we want to go ahead and
have a period so that's just going to be
a periodic scape that now we want the
hours minutes and seconds and for that
let's go ahead and do the full one and
again i don't have hours here but it's
going to be uppercase a then we want a
coal in a lowercase I for the minutes
and then just s for the seconds easy way
to remember this is just his so then
we want to do the blanket on here x own
time zone is just e as you can see here
identifies the time zone so II and that
should be it with sore totally possible
to the type of something but so let's
see what we did so throw that up there
let's refresh and now we've got it's
thursday the 27th of june 90 for
American Phoenix and this is actually
corresponds to the server time so the
time of the server is 904 you can also
throw in like a.m. or p.m. all kinds of
stuff like I've just got a few of these
so let's say we want to throw in the am
so we can throw in oops pop over here
space a so let's save that and put that
up come over here fresh so you can see
it okay it's not a 435 a and you know
you can keep refreshing it since it's
like the UNIX stamp you know that'll
keep going up in our seconds we'll keep
going up and so on anyway those are the
basics of timestamps the kind of letters
that you can do and you can do anything
with displaying a timestamp and if you
want to read more about it you go to
this php.net and them manual english
function date or just type in this URL
if i remember to i'll put it this
video's description as well it's real
helpful i mean they've got a different
way that you can displace those so it's
pretty cool so anyway as always thanks
for watching and stay tuned to this
video